sow sont bredouilles depuis plus de
trente ans il a été vu par plus de 140
millions de spectateurs dans mois
et cet hiver le fantôme de l'opéra
chantera en français à montréal et à
québec le livre l'histoire se passe à
paris le livre est écrit en français et
la traduction de nicolas angèle est
extraordinaire
elle est vraiment bien fait elle elle se
marie bien avec un musique d'une grande
histoire d'amour
il ya des côtés sombres à cette histoire
là mais de ça te rencontrer dans notre
langue
je son show sobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la version française avait écrit pour le
théâtre mogador de paris mais n'a
finalement jamais été présenté c'est
vraiment comme dans le show dans le fond
au bout d'un mois de répétitions il ya
eu un incendie à suresnes sur la scène
du coup et le show a été annulée en fait
parce que c'était prenait trop de temps
pour réparer le théâtre inspirée du
roman de gaston leroux il nous entraîne
dans les intérêts de l'opéra de paris ou
rendent un mystérieux fantôme qui est
des choses terribles qui se passe dans
l'histoire de fantômes et on parle
notamment de meurtre et de choses comme
ça donc la méchanceté je pense qu'elle
est présente mais c'est ce qui à la base
on voit que c'est un être extrêmement
passionné amoureux amoureux d'une belle
chanteuse promise l autre
justine pour moi elle est vraiment
amoureuse des de ces deux hommes elle
les aime pour des raisons différentes je
pense que le fantôme elle est fascinée
par sa personne par son talent et raul
on va dire que c'est le gentleman c'est
l'amoureux plus traditionnelle
contrairement spectacle original connu
pour sa scénographie impressionnante
il sera ici présenté en version concert
dépouillé de décor je trouve ça très
intéressant parce que on peut se
concentrer complètement sur la musique
et et met vraiment l'émotion a vraiment
dans la voix musicalement parlant c'est
fort la partition est riche et les
remplit quand on écoute que leur
qu'istres c'est déjà immense on ajoute
les voix qui viennent sa mélasse
c'est les airs qu'on a envie d'entendre
encore le célèbre phantom remonte sur
les planches en janvier de melgven et
avec cette nouvelle version française
l'équipe est confiante de parvenir à
conjurer le mauvais sort mais s'il est
bien un accent chartier radio canada
montréal